how many times a week should you fast
and how many times a day should you
recite the Lord's Prayer here but let
not your fast be with the
Hypocrites for they fast on the second
and fifth day of the week do the math
second day that's Monday fifth is
Thursday and there's an ancient
tradition that the Jews fasted Monday
and Thursday and Muhammad adopted that
tradition because he wanted to be a Jew
pleaser so when do you fast
Wednesday and Friday you see Catholics
Orthodox where you get the teaching of
your church that on Wednesday and Friday
you fast you get it from the apostles
right here for the longest time I
wondered why do Catholics the Assyrian
church and the Orthodox fast Wednesdays
and Fridays for the longest time no one
could give me an answer you see our
priest did us a disservice
if there were educated priests then they
probably would have saved
me 20 years of being a Protestant if
they had showed me the historical basis
for the Bible the church and the
teachings of the ancient
church and I knew Catholics fast from me
on Wednesdays and Fridays Orthodox and
Assyrian you guys see that again
Orthodox Assyrian Church Catholics you
have a tradition in common even though
you're in Schism which means that this
practice must predate your Schism if
you're all observing that practice but
you've been in Schism that means this
practice was something agreed upon
before you were in
Schism and the Assyrian church was
condemned and ostracized in the fifth
century 400s which means that this
practice was already implemented by the
church Universal before the fth Century
before the
400s no Sam the Lord tells you keep
asking keep seeking keep knocking don't
give up and you gave up and God still
answered you they got it from the
apostles to their
churches you caught
it yeah well Nico why don't you go visit
Pope Francis and have a discussion with
him but now watch here neither pray as
the Hypocrites but as the Lord commanded
his gospel how do you pray thus pray Our
Father who art in heaven Hallowed Be
Your Name Your Kingdom Come your will be
done as in heaven so on Earth give us
today our daily needful bread and
forgive us our debt as we also forgive
our debtors and bring us not into
temptation but Del from evil
one for yours is the power and the glory
forever how many times three times a day
Thrice in the day thus
pray that was another thing that used to
baffle me if I went to the Catholic
church or the Orthodox church or the
Assan Church they begin their prayers
with the Lord's Prayer right have you
noticed that even in your Bible studies
they be and I always wondered why why
are they repetitively reciting the
Lord's Prayer no one could tell me and
because of the goodness of God the
faithfulness of God seeing that my heart
was to know the fullness of the truth I
see why because the apostles taught that
to their
churches you see
it what about confessing and the
Eucharist let's see this was the PO the
point now you know now you teach so when
the Protestants go against this they're
not going against the Catholic church or
the Orthodox church the syan church
they're going against the apostles and
their heirs
okay you understand go say ' no we we
only go by the Bible we don't care what
you Catholics added or you Orthodox all
right well hold on this is a first
century document even acknowledges such
by Evangelical Protestants and I'm going
to play the clip and they're telling you
that this is written to the churches of
the Apostles and this is what they did
in
common
oops oops but let's go to confession
prayer after communion see all of this
read it
it's from the time of the Apostles man
it's important in fact there were
certain Christians who even wanted to
include it in the
Canon did you know that and are you
aware that the the
dascal which is later but based on the
dedic it's not the same as the deday
there's another writing called the
dascal teaching of the 12 that's based
on this right is part of the Ethiopian
Orthodox
Bible do you know
that now what about confessing now
Protestants you're going to have to
contend with this either Jesus failed
miserably to preserve his church because
even in the first century all of these
Misfits are introducing doctrines that
you say are uninspired doctrines of men
and the church are adopting these
practice universally so Christ failed to
preserve his church or lied because he
had no intention doing either which
means you're a blasphemer because you're
assaulting Christ because I want you to
explain this to me here it is chapter 14
you sabbatarians 7 Day Adventist the
Christians of the Apostles made it a
commandment to gather on the Lord's day
Sunday not your Saturday
here it
is and look what it says to do on Sunday
now I understood why the Catholic Church
the Orthodox church and the Assyrian
Church make it mandatory to have
Eucharist on Sunday let alone daily let
alone daily but I wonder why they do it
every week I also wonder that the
scripture says do this in remembrance of
me but you won't find it explicitly
stated to do it every week or even every
day
but because the priests were not
qualified they could not show me from
ancient sources from the apostles or
their disciples their
heirs because this was the practice of
the
church here right here but every Lord's
Day gather yourselves so it's a
commandment gather yourselves and break
bread and give Thanksgiving after what
damn Protestant what you going to do
what you going to do with this after
having confessed your transgressions
that sounds like confessing your sins in
the
church
damn but I thought that's the Catholic
teaching the Catholics corrupted the
church and the Catholics introduced all
these demonic Pagan doctrines fam
nowhere in the Bible that they confess
to man that they confess to God confess
your thing to God boy confess to
Jesus there you go right
here Focus everyone what do you going to
do this after having confessed your
transgressions why because if you're in
sin that you haven't confess you're
going to defile the Eucharist which they
call a sacrifice damn they even called
the Eucharist the
sacrifice that the
sacrifice that you offer is the UK of
our Lord
Jesus but let no one that is at variance
with his fellow come together with you
if you have grievance with your brother
do not come to church until you
reconcile with your brother quoting
Matthew until they be reconcile that
your sacri wait it's a sacrifice that we
partake of and offer when we take the
Eucharist for this is that which was
spoken by the Lord in every place and
time offer to me a pure sacrifice
quoting Malachi 1 6-4 specifically verse
11 for I am a great king says the Lord
and my name is wonderful among the
Nations
really so here's the link and this is
covered in the article that I uploaded
from Catholic answers whether you like
it or not C Protestants I'm sorry it's
going to offend you you have an unbroken
chain here's the article unbroken chain
from the first century from the time of
the Apostles for centuries an unbroken
chain writer after writer showing that
Christians were obligated to go to the
Eucharist and confess their sin in
church here it
is arenus the Gnostic disciple Marcus
have deluded many women some of these
women make a public confession but
others are ashamed to do this and in
silence as if withdrawing from
themselves the hope of the life of God
they either apostatize entirely or
hesitate between the two courses Sirus
is saying if you don't publicly confess
you're cutting yourself off from the
church don't be deceived by gnostics
ironically Protestants Protestants are
form gnosticism that even tertullian who
was not a church father look regarding
confession right some flee from this
work some run from coming to confession
as being exposure of the M themselves or
they put it off from day to day I
presume they are more mindful of modesty
than of Salvation what he's saying oh
you're more ashamed of someone hearing
your sins being confessed than you being
saved so what should you rather do hide
your sin and lose salvation or
acknowledge your sin in the church and
be forgiven like those who contracted
disease in the more shameful parts of
the body and Sh making themselves known
to the Physicians you see did you catch
it
why confession does not confirm what I
just
said yes it's Anonymous
brother did I not say confession is your
therapy your counseling session the
priest is your psychiatrist and the
Eucharist is your medicine here look
look at the
analogy like
those no toward Jesus God set up a
church with leaders
Bishops not just any Joo like those who
contract the disease in the more
shameful parts of the body and shun
making themselves known to the
Physicians Guess Who The Physicians are
guys the Bishops the priests and thus
they perish along with their own
bashfulness and the Lord saidou better
go to church and confess it to my
priests to my Bishops or you're not
honoring me
you caught it anyway you can read all
the quotes but I'm going to show you
what a Protestant says of the D there's
a lot more hippus
hippus
hippius right
origin okay it's right
here here let's read origin homes on Le
Leviticus a final method of forgiveness
albe it hard and laborious is the
remission of sin through Penance Penance
H Catholics when The Sinner does not not
shrink from declaring his sin to a
priest of the Lord and from seeking
medicine after the manner of him who say
I said to the Lord I will accuse myself
of my iniquity
damn unbroken chain guys look unbroken
chain from the first century to the
fifth century 400s
Jerome there you go there could have
been more quotes but you get it
right yeah if you don't want to confess
that the parish where all the your
family members go go to different
Parish okay you got
it all right now Focus help me to help
you stay focused on me now let me show
you what a Protestant says about the
diday you ready how important the diday
is Protestant says about the dedic watch
here I'm play the clip this is Michael
bird he's not a he's not a Catholic he's
an Anglican but he's considered renowned
Evangelical scholar okay let's see what
he says this guy with the Beautiful
dental work right here Michael bird
beautiful listen what he's goingon to
say about the
D so why should you be reading or
studying or even know about the D well
to begin with besides the New Testament
the D is arguably one of the most
ancient non-conical text in existence do
you hear
that do you hear it
do you hear what he said apart from the
New Testament Canon the deday is
arguably one of the most ancient
non-canonical texts in existence it's
Protestant
dude uh this is one of the most
important texts for the study of early
Christianity this is a text that puts us
in direct contact with the practices and
prayers of the Primitive Church wow one
of the most important documents of the
ancient church and puts
us
in that period of History telling us how
the Primitive Church practiced did you
hear
it in addition the D demonstrates that
the early church was still well and
truly connected to its Jewish roots in
terms of its ethics worship devotion
Ministries and
theology furthermore the D is one of the
primary Witnesses for the origins and
development of Christianity in places
like Syria did you hear it the dedic is
an important historical document on the
origin of Chris Christianity in
Syria and we can maybe even wonder if we
can be more specific than that maybe it
tells us about the shape of Christianity
in somewhere like Antioch or Damascus or
even somewhere like adessa you got the
link right you heard it from a
Protestant